y
vale
cualquier problema que tengas en tu vida
la solución está en las ventas piénsalo
la solución está en las ventas crisis
económica ventas quieres un aumento de
sueldo ventas un ascenso tal vez ventas
pixar tu emprendimiento frente a un
panel de inversionistas ventas
encontrar pareja para casarte así es
créelo no vengas y es que todos somos
vendedores nos guste o no todos siempre
estamos vendiendo algo hagamos
conciencia de ello no podemos ser
víctimas o podemos ser como ser víctimas
de esta desgracia horrible o también por
nuestra conciencia y utilizar esto para
lograr el bien común me dio la tarea
conforme estaba platiqué preparando para
esta charla de preguntarle a la gente
preguntarle a la gente que forma parte
de mi comunidad a quienes consideraban
exitosos ya la tarea de estudiar cada
uno de ellos me di cuenta que todos
tenían algo en común y es que todos eran
grandes vendedores voy a permitir
utilizar sus propias palabras para
ejemplificar un punto dando la mejor
forma de encontrarse ahora mismo es
perdiéndose dando servicio a los demás
que el hedor sasso no tenemos la
definición equivocada de vender que hoy
más que vender es igual a manipular a
mentir a hacer lo que sea con tal de
cerrar una venta
eso es todo menos un vendedor
definición fuerte de ventas es una sola
palabra ayudar tu haces esto el
suficiente número de veces y tendrás
como consecuencia la posibilidad de
hacer una enorme fortuna
y es que hoy en día nadie quiere ser
vendedor
ayúdame a la audiencia contestando o
llenando la siguiente frase de kristen
bell o
échale ganas a la escuela si no es a
terminar
búscate un trabajo y aunque sea
tuve un dolor imagínense ustedes pero no
es la estúpida creencia limitante aparte
de que ventas es el último eslabón en la
cadena alimenticia de que no hay cosa
más manipuladora y mentirosa que ser un
vendedor más aparte si nos ha vendido la
idea desde temprana edad de que ventas
es igual a ser un fracasado por eso nos
sentimos en la necesidad de poner
cualquier cosa en nuestra tarjeta de
presentación camuflajear la con palabras
rimbombantes como gerente comercial
asesor ejecutivo lo que sea menos
ponerle con orgullo vendedor
quién en su sano juicio teniendo esta
creencia limitante y creyendo ser un
fracasado y un su sano juicio va a
querer ser vendedor o lo que es más si
ya llegaste ahí como consecuencia de
mala suerte por necesidad porque ocupas
una chamba y luego querer hacer bien los
seres humanos somos buenos por
naturaleza siguientes es igual a fracaso
siguiente es igual a manipulación porque
vamos a querer hacerlo bien si tienes
esa creencia limitante desde acá
hay que hacer ese cambio de paradigma
hay que hacer ese cambio montás es igual
a ayudar
jesucristo era un gran vendedor
y este gran señor en una sola frase da
lo que a mí me toma un libro poder
demostrar
pide y se te dará siempre busca y
encontrarás
prospección toca la puerta y esa puerta
se te abrirán llamadas en frío
en sólo unas cuantas palabras te acaba
de dar una cátedra este enorme super
vendedor y es que soy un soy a
ver por qué
mi inteligencia no me permite entender
que en pleno 2019 exista gente pobre no
puede ser que el aire de los smartphone
el aire de los dragones de los carros
solares exista gente que batalla para
comer para que para poder cubrir sus
necesidades más básicas y tiene que
recurrir a actos delictivos como robar
algunas otras cosas tal vez mi
inteligencia no me da para entender eso
parte de mi lucha y aprovecho este medio
es de llevar la materia de ventas como
parte de la educación básica en américa
latina no nada más creo no nada más creo
que esto va a tener un impacto positivo
en la economía de esos países sino
también va a tener un impacto positivo
en la seguridad de esas comunidades y la
razón es muy sencilla uno no puede ser
pobre si sabe vender
bueno yo creo que te vende la idea de
convertirse en vendedor de invitarte a
este equipo de acá
el mundo desde los vendedores y te
quiero demostrar en sólo unos cuantos
puntos puedes entrar en este equipo
puntos muy sencillos para hacerlo con
éxito no importa si eres empleado una
compañía gerardo yo estoy en otro
departamento no tengo nada que ver con
ventas mentira eres de un dedo
el primer paso es negocia un ingreso
variable no no importa en el
departamento que estés negocia un
ingreso variable preparándome para esta
charla y contacte a diferentes amigos
empresarios ninguno de ellos estaba vivo
no aceptará esta idea absolutamente
todos decían que estaban totalmente
abiertos a negociar un ingreso variable
así forma es parte del departamento de
limpieza de una compañía negocia un
ingreso variable tal vez necesites
barrer un poco más rápido y en ese
tiempo que te quedó libre porque no y
descargar el archivo viejo de los
clientes y nativos y poder contactar y
rescatar una cuenta una buena comisión o
un buen bono
tal vez un bono de productividad pero
negocia un ingreso variable
el siguiente punto es define tus metas
los seres humanos creemos que tenemos la
vida comprada creemos que lo tenemos
todo gratis y quién sabe que te vaya a
pasar mañana
tenemos la vida tan gratis que nos
permitimos hacernos una pregunta tan
pendeja como por qué razón estoy vivo
para que estoy en este mundo y el día de
mañana puede no estar creo que la
pregunta es qué quieres tú de esta vida
qué quieres tú de este mundo dije que me
llegan todos los días
vendedores pidiéndome ayuda con sus
metas con sus sueños y cuando les
pregunto sobre esto sobre cuáles son sus
metas lo que me contestan es una casa
más grande
quiero llevar a mis hijos a la mejor
universidad yo les contesto cómo es esa
casa más grande si es un nuestro mayor
ya cumpliste tu sueño y ha cumplido tu
meta no yo quiero una más grande todavía
bueno de qué color es cuántos cuartos
tiene en qué colonia en qué ciudad de
que con marc estilo de fachada tiene esa
casa de tus sueños mediano está está
lograda si lo hagas traducirla en un
papel porque por lo menos ya sabes qué
es lo que tienes que hacer para lograr
dicha meta la mejor universidad cuánto
cuesta un semestre en la mejor
universidad ese es medio camino para
lograrlo tener pintado bien el panorama
es medio camino para lograrlo nada más
es cuestión de vender lo suficiente ya
estás ahí el siguiente punto es define
tu cliente de valor a qué me refiero con
esto quién es esta persona quién va a
valorar tu oferta quién es esta persona
quién se va a sentir quién va a
satisfacer una necesidad con tu producto
tu servicio hace el perfil así como si
fueras un detective
hace un perfil completo y después hasta
la pregunta dónde puedo encontrar más
personas así
y muy básico sería ahí tienes que pasar
la mayor cantidad de tu tiempo
tú me diste una frase que me encanta
otra enorme vendedor la gente exitosa
hacen mejores preguntas y como resultado
obtiene mejores respuestas la
herramienta clave de cualquier vendedor
se llama preguntas los discursos de
ventas una folletería no tarjetas de
presentación mucho menos una
presentación que llevas en tu
computadora la mejor herramienta de un
vendedor se llama preguntas hay que
descubrir las verdaderas necesidades de
nuestros prospectos cuál es ese problema
a resolver cuál es ese dolor a sanar
cuál es ese placer que busca generar o
generarse
tú descubres esto el factor precio
comienza a disminuir porque entonces le
estás hablando a lo que las personas lo
que la persona que tienes enfrente de
verdad quiere
ofrece soluciones una vez que tienes
claro cuál es este verdadero problema
puedes ofrecer una solución no tiene
pruebas a dar un discurso de ventas sin
tener en claro cuál es la verdadera
necesidad de tu cliente los vendedores
no estamos para discutir características
si nuestro motor está dicho con la mejor
calidad con los mejores ingenieros desde
1980 etc no importa eso cualquier
persona la puede ser locutor cualquier
persona puede leer un folleto y leer ese
alguien más no cualquiera puede
descubrir esa verdadera necesidad y
ayudarle a la persona que tiene enfrente
ofrece soluciones y para hacer esto
primero necesitas descubrir cuál es eso
a solucionar este me encanta actúa con
intención lo que se acaba de hacerlo con
la intención de ser lo mejor de hacerlo
lo mejor posible hace esa llamada
hazla con intención mandas a correr el
seguimiento hazlo con intención habla
sobre tu producto sobre tu servicio
sobre tu sobre la asesoría que das hazlo
con intención de ayudarle a la otra
persona
habla con la intención de cerrar ese
negocio hazlo con la intención de que
esa otra persona reciba la bondad de tu
producto otro servicio
invita a tomar acción que acabo de decir
que las ventas en una sola palabra sería
ayudar
no hemos ayudado a nadie todavía
entiendo muchos vendedores hay muchas
personas que no quieren entrar a este
mundo porque le tienen temor a que le
digan que no quieren temor a sentir ese
rechazo
y por eso en la última etapa del proceso
de ventas se congelan y no hace nada
sin embargo si estamos hablando y
partiendo de que ventas es igual a
ayudar no le estás ayudando a nadie a
menos que lo invites a tomar acción
esa es la verdadera ayuda si tú
productos y tus servicios en la idea que
quieres vender en verdad me beneficiar a
la otra persona entonces es tu
obligación estarías haciendo un test
favor si no cierras esa venta
y ahora sí ayudarle a la mayor cantidad
de personas posibles hay un mundo allá
afuera hay muchísimas personas quienes
van a valorar tu oferta
no pienses que la competencia no pienses
que ya todo está hecho hay muchísimas
personas muchísimas empresas quienes se
pudieran ver beneficiados por lo que tú
estás ofreciendo
hay que verlo con abundancia
responsabilízate sigo hablándole a que
el personal de limpieza
sigo hablándole a aquella secretaria
sigo hablándole a ese empleado de
mantenimiento
decimos enorme cantidad de mensajes
gerardo dije fe no me quiere gerardo mi
jefe es muy malo conmigo me exige mucho
yo lo que les digo es tú eres tu propio
jefe los vendedores
somos nuestro propio jefe que empresario
tuvo nada que ver cuidar a la vaquita de
oro a quien trae los dólares a quien
trae los pesos a quien trae la lana a la
compañía y no nada más eso cuando digo
responsabilízate me refiero a que tu
jefe malo tu jefe tóxico es solamente
una proyección del jefe y la verdad es
un ojete del jefe que de verdad es un
negrero estás proyectando en los demás
lo que no has querido ver en ti por
consecuencia tienes un objeto de
jefe
steve jobs decía mantente hambriento
mantente alocado pues este luego con
muchísima hambre te dice que solamente
eres un medio así es los seres humanos
solamente somos un canal solamente somos
un medio para ayudar a los demás y sigo
hablando de ventas porque lo que
nosotros hacemos mediante nuestro
producto nuestro servicio es que la
persona que lo consume obtenga un
impacto positivo en su vida
[Música]
solamente somos un canal para ayudar
pero también este canal esté en medio de
las ventas también es un medio para
nosotros obtener lo que nosotros
queramos
si por ejemplo tu pasión está en ayudar
animales que están en peligro de
extensión extinción y tienes un empleo
de vendedor de zapatos que padre eso
quiere decir que mientras más zapatos
vendas más animales en peligro de
extinción puedes ayudar estás en una
posición afortunada yo me despido
agradeciendo que en este momento porque
justo en este segundo y en este lugar
yo estoy siendo un medio y con un
poquito de fuerza de suerte estoy siendo
un medio quien te sacudió lo suficiente
para que a partir de hoy hagas algo
diferente porque amigas y amigos el
mundo el mundo hacer los vendedores
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]